because as you mentioned there were
incidents still taking place there was
the funeral they're also protests and
uncomfortable questions being asked in
the lead up to the funeral of how
protests and a state funeral could
co-exist in the capital they did
um approach anti-monarchy process and
also those turning out in support of
Chris caber now we saw those protests
the weekend before we saw them at this
weekend
um and the family of Chris Caba had the
three demands of the first protest met
the officer who fired the shot suspended
the family will get to see the body cam
footage this week and they now know how
long the investigation is due to take
they've been told six to nine months but
Sky News was at that protest this
weekend and for some of those there
that's still not moving swiftly enough
do you think six to nine months is a
reasonable amount of time for an
investigation into something like this
a little on a pulse and again my
condolences to Chris Carver's family uh
his loved ones and the community the
reality is you know black londoners are
concerned about this incident it's one
of a number of incidents that has led to
Black londoners having less confidence
in the Police Service than they should
the family and the community have many
questions that deserve answers uh the
independent police Watchdog is
independent but they're cognizant and
aware of the concerns uh there are
they're also obvious they also know the
importance of earning back trust and
confidence not just in the police
Watchdog but in the Police Service as
well I think it is important for for all
of us to recognize that armed officers
uh you have to make split circumcisions
but once they discharge their weapon
they are understandably under intense
scrutiny that's right because we've got
to make sure the police are properly
pleased and that gives us confidence
when we police by uh consent I'm sure
both the Police Service in relation to
the new commissioner Mark Rowley the
independent police Watchdog will ensure
there's a proper robust thorough
investigation which includes answering
the questions the community has making
sure that where it's possible uh the
concerns the family have can be
addressed
yeah it's one final question as you said
due process is now taking its course
um just talking to some of the
protesters in the crowds at the weekend
just to quote some of them a gentleman
called Chris sibia said we want equal
rights just like everyone else you know
if this happens to another group it
seems Justice is Swift in the black
community it's always lacking another
protester said I don't feel protected so
I want to know when I feel protected by
the police rather than having to be
scared of the police you talk about
earning Trust of course it's due process
into the Chris Caba case one particular
case is happening but there is this
disconnect between the black community
and the police in London what are you
doing that's real and tangible to bridge
that Gap
well trust and Confidence from the black
community and the police plummeted over
the course of the last couple of years
one of the reasons I lost confidence in
the former commissioner was me not
accepting the plan she had to both
address the issues that have been raised
over the last couple of years but also
plan to win back the trust and
confidence one of the things I was
looking for in a new commissioner was
for he or she to be a reforming
commissioner so Mark Rowley the new
commissioner has confirmed he does want
to be a reforming commissioner he's been
distracted of course over the course of
the last week in his first week in his
job with making sure Her Majesty's uh
you know funeral could take place
successfully and safely but he's been
working around the clock at the same
time with a plan to win back trust and
confidence in the police he's you know
as passionate as I am for those
communities and that includes by the way
women and girls that includes by the way
many from the lgbtq plus Community uh
that includes many black uh londoners
who haven't had the confidence in that
police that they should have uh working
hard to earn back that trust and
confidence and by the way having more
trust and confidence is linked with
reducing crime because as members of the
public we need to come forward and
Report crime be Witnesses join the
police service and that leads to Crime
coming down
at mayor of London a really busy weekend
for the police across London and as you
said so new recruits coming down to the
capital as well this weekend we
appreciate you talking to us about a
whole range of issues there thank you
for your time